Oh Denzel, tu sais qu'il ne veut pas
que quelqu'un d'autre fasse ses
cascades et c'est génial qu'il l'
aborde de ce point de vue
évidemment si quelque chose va être trop
dangereux pour lui ou tu sais que nous pensons
que c'est dangereux alors  nous lui avons parlé de
nous y travaillons, mais c'est un
soldat que vous devez entrer dans un truc et
agir comme si vous pilotiez l'avion et
pendez la tête en bas vous savez que c'est
toujours un enfant je veux dire c'est le plaisir de ça
c'est c'est un  excellent travail, nous avons trois
types de base de Gimbels aidant à faire fonctionner l'
avion, l'un est une base de mouvement, il ne prend pas tout
le poids de l'avion entier,
nous devons donc utiliser uniquement des sections lorsque
nous filmons sur cette pièce et ainsi nous
pouvons vraiment obtenir l'avion  au fur et à mesure que cela commence à
s'inverser dans l'histoire,
ils font des recherches sur notre scénario
et et et le parcourent avec notre
réalisateur, nous réalisons que l'avion
traverse différentes couches de problèmes,
nous avons donc choisi d'utiliser des méthodes logicielles pour
le secoué  le c  des bruits qui
seraient des airbags que nous pouvons contrôler
ce poids et le déplacer de haut en bas et
et et en quelque sorte lui donner l'idée que
nous flottons à travers les nuages, c'est un
peu comme si vous aviez une Impala 64 que vous
cherchiez à sauter  et vers le bas ouais mais
vous savez ce qu'est un énorme
fuselage large qui sautille de haut en bas
et je me suis senti mal à l'aise rien qu'en regardant
le moniteur, j'étais comme si je ne voulais pas,
je n'arrêtais pas de dire que je ne voulais pas être dans
cet avion  ça n'a jamais l'air d'être
sur scène j'étais comme si je m'en fichais je
ne veux toujours pas être dans cet avion